welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the hella fast youtuber that's here
to bring you everything you need to know
about kang the conqueror
now in episode 6 of loki we learned that
the entire tva was masterminded by a
version of nathaniel richards
known as he who remains richards told of
a multiversal war that had almost
wiped out all life in existence because
his variants couldn't decide who had the
nicest shoes
and thus he had wiped out entire
timelines in order to avoid facing up to
himself
he who remains gave loki and sylvia
choice either they could take over his
role and carry on the tva's fascist
regime
or they could kill him and allow the
multiverse to spring into action
this would usher forth an infinite
amount of ganks and we were left asking
if it's better the devil you know
now he he remains final words where i'll
see you soon
and with jonathan mages propped up to
appear in ant-man quantomania
it's pretty clear that kang will be
coming sooner rather than later
but who is kang and which variants
should we be worried about
well throughout this video we're going
to be breaking down the character as
well as his best and worst versions
from across the multiverse if you enjoy
the breakdown then please smash the
thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe with every
single variant of you
in order to stop a multi-video war
between myself and ryan harry
now before talking about all the
variants of richards i think we have to
discuss the characters origins in the
comics
the next part of the video will go over
the story of his life and how he came to
be established as one of the biggest
marvel villains ever
nathaniel was born in the 31st century
and he was a descendant of reed richards
aka mr fantastic obsessed with history
and time travel
richard studied how to manipulate the
time stream and after mastering this he
decided to journey through it in order
to conquer different timelines
throughout the multiverse
now as we learned in avengers endgame
every time you travel back in time
there is the possibility that you can
create a branch in reality
in which a timeline travels off into its
own direction
each and every time richards journeyed
into the past and affected events there
he in turn created an alternate version
of himself and this is how there's so
many variants
and the first one we have to talk about
is rama tut
richard's first major journey through
the time stream was to ancient egypt
and the character traversed the time
stream on a sphynx shaped ship
which allowed him to blend in because
yeah if there's one thing everyone did
back then
it's right around in a big spaceship now
hints towards this could actually be
seen in the void in loki episode 5
when we saw a sphinx with its nose
intact and this is actually
very similar looking to the one that
turt had side tangent it is possible
that the artifacts and locations we saw
in the void
were pulled and called kang timelines
and this is why we also saw that
avengers tower that had the kang logo on
it
anyway as turd he wanted to claim enza
bernie
aka apocalypse as his heir the character
debuted in the fantastic 419
and he quickly established himself as a
powerful pharaoh
during this time tut's rules seemed like
it could be everlasting
however he was defeated by the fantastic
four who had been displaced out of their
timeline
speaking of four and time how do you
know when a clock is hungry
it always goes back four seconds say
having that so it's a way i tell them
now defeated
richards ended up traveling to the 20th
century where he came face to face with
dr doom
who he believed might also be an
ancestor of his
riches was obviously bitterly
disappointed with his defeat at the
hands of the fantastic four
and the next phase of the character was
the scarlet centurion
which had armor that was based on doom's
designs the pair first met in the
fantastic four annual two
and it was one of the most important
moments in richard's life
as he became highly influenced by the
super villain
years later several variants of richards
would end up fusing together
in order to create doom the annihilating
conqueror this is by far one of the most
terrifying and fearsome versions of the
villain
and a combined doctor doom and ils and
iron lad who we'll talk about later
now as the centurion he attempted to
defeat the avengers but the character
was bested
and forced from the timeline richards
tried to return to the 31st century
however he ended up overshooting by a
thousand years and he came across an
earth that had been decimated by war
luckily for kang because of the need for
soldiers scientists had sort of died out
and the humans were forced to use
weapons and technologies that they knew
how to use
but didn't really know how to create
kang ended up conquering this world
easily
and it's here that he became kang the
conqueror the most infamous version of
the character
he developed his technology and armor
which allowed him to gain increased
strength
and durability it's at this time he
ended up setting up the damocles base
which like its namesake was shaped like
a sword
on board with his legion of foot
soldiers and he used these to ravage
anything that he wished to take over
during this time the character also fell
for ravona rentslayer
who was a princess at one of his many
kingdoms that location was part of an
uprising
and after kang refused to execute her
this led to a revolt
and thus kang has sort of gone from
timeline to timeline attempting to
restore his former glory
now kang did return to egypt and he
ruled his ramatap for 10 years
before placing himself in suspended
animation in order to wait it out until
the 20th century
this all built towards the celestial
madonna story
in which kang ended up attempting to
marry mantis because
she was apparently destined to bear a
child that would be one of the most
powerful beings in the universe
now it's also during this that it was
revealed that the character immortus was
actually an
older variant of kang and most of the
versions that live long enough
end up becoming him the design of he who
remains was actually based heavily on
immortus
and the mcu version is somewhat of an
amalgamation between him
and well he who remains now immortus is
somewhat of a good guy that has actually
helped the avengers from time to time
and he's basically you when you watch
videos of yourself
from 10 years ago he finds himself super
cringe
and doesn't really want the past version
of himself to take over the universe
as he was young foolish and didn't
thumbs up videos
so everyone hated him thus immortus and
kang have been trapped in an almost
everlasting war
and the most notable happening of this
occurred in the comic avengers forever
in which the two went head to
head-to-head immortes is basically a
more powerful
and far more knowledgeable version of
kang and he learned a wealth of things
from the timekeepers
who you will of course be aware of due
to the series
they taught him a lot of cosmic
information and gave him the power that
allowed him
to prune and delete his numerous
variants however immortus's worst nature
got the better of him
and we learned that during this that he
was actually also trying to establish
himself as the ruler of all time
which no doubt hints towards what may
have happened before the events of what
we see in the show
either way he and his younger self have
been locked in an infinite war
and because of this several versions and
variants have come forth
the first majorly interesting one i want
to touch upon is kamala kang ms marvel
is of course coming down the line on
disney plus
and there is potential that we might see
here one day during the events of the
infinity wars comic book storyline
gamora ended up bending and folding
reality and this meshed several
characters together
kamala possessed all the technical and
scientific knowledge that kang had
and on top of this she brought with her
her ability to shapeshift
by far one of the most powerful versions
of kang i would absolutely love to see
her pop up in the mcu at some point
now another version of kang is iron lad
who ended up forming the young avengers
with the likes of wiccan and speed as
well as eli bradley all popping up in
the shows
it's possible that iron lad 2 could be
coming down the line in order to help
form the team
he wears a suit of armor similar to tony
stark's and it's able to change
shape with a thought he's definitely one
of the strongest in the young avengers
team
and it makes a lot of sense that he
could pop about some time too
other notable versions are victor timely
a version of richards who journeyed back
in time to 1901
and here he set up the town timely in
wisconsin
get it because he's called timely and he
messes with time
lee now the name victor is also not
evictive on doom
and he's got a lot of cool easter eggs
attached to him after first showing up
in avengers annual 21
timely has appeared from time to time
and he was actually the character whose
experiments led to the original android
human torch who you may know from timely
comics
timely comics eventually changed its
name to atlas comics
and atlas comics ended up becoming the
marvel comics that we know today
so viktor has a number of meta things
surrounding him and i think it would be
a great wing to the audience to have him
show up
the last variant i think has a high
possibility of being in the mcu
is mr griffin griffin actually ended up
purchasing avengers tower from tony
stark
and out of it he ran his company king
industries
using his technology skills he managed
to possess the vision
something that we already saw hey would
do in one division
potentially it could turn out that he
was the one who helped the fun
sword with their experiments and with
the king building already showing up
i think it would be great to see him
appear anyway that should cover
everything you need to know about kang
and his variants now obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts on the character
and what you want to see in the mcu so
make sure you leave them in the comments
below
we are running a competition right now
and giving away three mcu box sets on
the 30th of july
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on kang we picked the comments
at random at the end of the month and
the winners of the last one are on
screen right now
so message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if that's you
if you want some emails to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
everything we know about season 2 which
will be linked on screen right now we've
gone over all the little bits of info we
know
and also talked about some of the things
we learned in the behind the scenes
special
so definitely go watch it if you want to
know more about the series
without the way thank you for singing
through this i've been paul i'll see you
next time
take care peace